Drexel University band inconsiderate
jokes and wait for me inappropriately
directed laughter I'm Jeremy with Greg
blue gown off who is among many things
he's the first ever recipient of the
Playboy Foundation freedom of expression
award I had to mention it though I had
to mention that at the Museum of sex
now Greg is he said he's a lawyer and an
author of a terrific new book called
unlearning Liberty campus censorship in
the end of American debate and it tells
about his struggles as the as a lawyer
and as the head of fire which is the
foundation for individual rights in
education and they have been fighting
the good fight against campus censorship
defending students rights in protecting
this thing called the First Amendment
which is of all places in the world you
think that that the Academy would be a
place the treasures at but it turns out
to be one of the most restrictive places
and Greg has been doing just a great job
fighting it's a great book and we had
planned to start talking about some of
the stories in it some of the about the
new Victorians on campus who are
censoring all kinds of obscenities
becoming anything at all but there were
some news last week that we want to
start with it's really too important and
at the risk of offending someone here
and violating a new federal law great
what the [ __ ] happened was yeah I came
prepared with all sorts of cute stories
and after being asked to do the Museum
of Sex speech there was a conveniently
weirdly but also sadly for the students
a real uptake and in sort of traditional
cases where you know there was a
newspaper in New Mexico a student
newspaper in New Mexico that produced a
sex edition and it got censored by the
by the administration they gathered up
all the copies of it they confiscated it
and they put it earlier basically a
proud statement on the website
explaining yeah we shut it down because
we didn't like the content of the
newspaper so there's been a big uptick
in cases like that but this has all been
completely eclipsed by the fact that and
to give a little bit a little bit of
background the what a lot of people
don't understand is that
iseman has been the go-to theory for
speech code since the 1980s this is not
coincidence this is very intentional
the-the-the the people who sort of
considered the sort of forebears of
speech code theory on campus in the 80s
are people like Mary Matsuda and Richard
Delgado and they always said that that
the way we can go after if speech that's
offensive on the basis of race and
gender is through harassment codes and
this and these have been defeated in
decision after decision since 1989
because the courts don't fall for this
sleight of hand you can't just dump
something harassment but then redefine
it is anything that offends anybody
which they've done but this gets
defeated in courts this get defeated in
the court of public opinion over and
over again and fire in it's nearly 15
years we've been fighting for a
definition that we radically borrowed
from the Supreme Court of what
harassment should mean it's called in
case called Davis the only case that
actually deals with the state of
harassment law as it applies to the
educational framework that that actually
considers First Amendment considerations
and the impossibility of preventing
people from being offended all the time
that it has a narrow cure that workable
definition of harassment that we've been
advocating for and we're getting great
progress we every single speech code
lawsuit we've been involved in we've won
it's been nothing but victories against
these kind of codes because they're
laughably unconstitutional well we have
editorials talking about this we got on
the hill we explained that we want to
just get this to be a clear narrow
definition to prevent the kind of
shenanigans we see in on college
campuses thought we were totally winning
this fight and then on Thursday in the
context of a letter to the University of
Montana to deal with sexual assault
cases for some reason the Department of
Education and the Department of Justice
took it upon itself to redefine
harassment instead of this narrowly
tailored definition to this any
unwelcome sexual sexual speech that's it
and they and the other thing that they
did was they eliminated the reasonable
person the objective standard the the
one thing that actually prevented there
was at least in theory supposed to
prevent you from being brought up on
frivolous
ridiculous charges was the idea that
it's supposed to be both subjectively
offensive and objectively offensive by
objectively offensive that means that
it's something that your average person
would find highly offensive not not just
that it's limited to you know the most
sensitive person the room they
explicitly got rid of the objective
standard so we now have any unwelcome
sexual speech that any anybody finds
offensive even if unreasonable is now
defined as harassment they completely
divorced the idea of severe persistent
and pervasive they completely dismissed
the Davis decision and the plaintiff you
take the plain language of this code
seriously and it believe me everybody
does on college campuses everybody looks
at what the Department of Education says
about this stuff because they have all
the control over title nine funding and
they'll all and they have control over
all federal funding of university so
there's an entire industry that watches
what the entire at the Department of
Education has to say about this and
they've just redefined harassment to
make every single man woman and child
every single faculty member arguably
guilty of harassment in one fell swoop
and they miss Corder the Supreme Court
in this case they miscoded the Davis
opinion yeah that that was definitely
for the legal perfectionist that fire we
were like you and you at the temerity to
misquote the Davis opinion in the course
of what kind of lawyers are you certain
words right yeah yeah that they left out
that they talked about it being severe
and and pervasive when the actual quote
is I think severe persistent and
objectively offensive and that and and
they so they quoted Davis without
quoting one of the most important parts
of Davis how does something like this
happen is this that I mean it's a
government by community organizers now
that Obama's people are kind of taken
over these agencies I mean how does this
happen something that that outrageous
yeah I've been wondering about that but
they're definitely since 2009 since the
first the Department of Education had
actually been at least comparatively
sort of calm on these issues like in
2003 they actually issued a letter to
all the schools across the country
saying wait we see now that these codes
are being abused to punish first a
member protected speech so therefore we
want to be very clear we have no power
to make you punish First Amendment
speech we don't want you to punish first
remember
speech and if you pass harassment codes
that violate First Amendment standards
you do that on your own and take your
own risk they did not mention this
letter at all they didn't mention the
First Amendment they didn't mention free
speech they didn't mention their own
2003 explicit letter in the in the
course of this Montana
letter but this has been unfortunately a
part of what's been happening in the
department education is for there was at
first a letter of guidance that was
about bullying and and it dealt it had a
pretty broad definition of bullying then
there was there against bullying they're
against bully again
then there was another one that the one
that really troubled us back in 2011 on
April 4th when they issued a letter
saying that that in order to deal with
the very real problem of sexual assault
on campus since we only have
jurisdiction over harassment and
arguably harassment is just a very
severe form of assault that in order to
increase a very severe form of
harassment that in order to increase
people getting in trouble for this you
have to lower the confidence with which
you convict someone that on this to
preponderance of evidence which is the
lowest legally allowable standard that
you can be found guilty under so you
know we were talking about so you're
saying that harassment is a offence so
serious we have to be less sure it
actually happened and so this is this is
a double whammy that we're seeing here
is that you've lowered the and I talked
about this in the book that the the
double whammy is defined everything as
harassment to find everything as banned
and then lower the confidence with which
you can find people guilty of it um and
so I like looking at this letter I just
don't understand how a university could
possibly comply with it so what what can
be done they what is fired doing and
what can students do what can alumni do
about it well
right now we're just trying to educate
people we're trying to put it in simple
terms as possible because I mean we live
in the first amendment law but we're
weirdly specialized in this so when we
looked at the letter we looked at what
the language but the fact that they
completely rule out Davis the fact that
they create this new separate definition
of harassment as distinct from hostile
environment which had never been been
the case before you know when we first
publicized about it I thought we have to
wait a couple days
or people are like oh my god they're
right so we're still in the stage of
just educating the public about it but
it's gonna you know definitely alumni
the thing that the thing that was
frustrating about the Dear Colleague
letter though the one where they lowered
the standard of proof was that
universities weren't willing to fight
this and I talked to administrators in
private and they're like oh it's been
terrible since the Dear Colleague letter
came out because we have to adjudicate
on all of these offenses at this really
low standard and we we just don't feel
qualified to be able to do this but they
weren't willing to fight it out in
public this code that this new guidance
letter though goes so far and it's so
impossible for universities to comply
with I'm hopeful that at least some
universities will just say we'll stand
up and push back because but if not it's
going to be you know students who are
convicted under this they're gonna have
that they should litigate and they
should litigate and they should name the
Department of Education and the
Department of Justice and it's not a
close call that's kind of code that the
Department of Education is recommended
you know that they it's it's clearly
established in First Amendment law going
back decades that this this will not
stand
so definitely alumni you know contacting
their alma mater it's telling them to
stand up to this is tremendously helpful
reading up on it yourself is really
helpful and I've been glad to see so far
that whether I'm talking about this to
the National Review or to Huffington
Post live people are like yeah this is
ridiculous now this fire suggested as
someone else suggests that that Friends
of the First Amendment could start
filing all kinds of complaints on campus
again say the Department of Women's
Studies for making because men feel you
know men feel harassed by this and feel
I mean its offensive right so the thing
I'm always afraid about that the
strategy of let's just co-op this and
show how ridiculous it is is I'm afraid
that universities would be okay with
that they would actually say stuff to
the effect that well you know we really
do want to prevent an offensive
atmosphere so really let's just shut
everybody up and and and this isn't I
used to make this as a joke but it's
becoming less and less far-fetched like
the the the the problem of free speech
zones on college campuses we had to
actually go into court to fight a school
University of Cincinnati for goodness
sakes bound by the First Amendment
who limited free speech activities
point one percent of campus and still
require ten days advance notice in order
to use that point one percent
the University of Cincinnati was willing
to go into court to defend that and
that's the thing it's kind of like one
of the reasons why this is a problem is
it's fear of liability it's ignorant of
these principles it's but it's also mass
you know mass bureaucratization and
ultimately you know they're more in some
cases they're more concerned about peace
and quiet on campus than anything else
in the book you mentioned how especially
at prestige schools at Harvard do you
say that the students are afraid I mean
even students who who who've been
victims of these absurd codes are afraid
to bring a case is that right yeah
that's one thing that that I really
tried to emphasize in the book probably
the think year aspect of the book is
that we've gotten kind of dismissive of
you know what's roughly and somewhat
dismissively referred to as a political
correctness on campus and we when we
give these incredible stories I mean I
open up the book talking about a student
who was literally kicked out of college
because he made a collage criticizing a
parking garage and students did not care
of faculty members did not care nobody
came to his defense other other than
fire
meanwhile the all right afraid right so
one of my points is that censorship
doesn't really make people doesn't make
people change their minds what it does
is it pushes people to not talk to
people they disagree with and if you got
crude jokes if you got a body sense of
humor you just say that to your friend
who gets it if you have if you're a
conservative or if you're a liberal you
just follow three simple rules don't
talk to people you disagree with don't
disagree with the professor whose ego
can't take it and don't and and join the
ideological groups that reflect what you
already already believe and if you do
those three things it's easy-peasy
you're not gonna have a problem on two
on college campuses these days but the
problem is that's supercharging
everything that's wrong with our entire
society is we're all already talking to
people we already agree with so um and
the the the problem of this group
polarization is something I really
emphasize in the book and it's only
helpful
by the threat by the threat of
punishment but one of the most
interesting statistics that I came
across in the book was a study of 24,000
students they are asked this milquetoast
question is it safe to hold unpopular
positions on campus and that's that's a
question that's designed to be a
whitewash that's the question that's
designed to get everyone to go of course
it's safe to merely hold and popular
points of view on campus you know I just
talked to the people I already agree
with I don't disagree with my professors
whatever I could hold them nonetheless
even though is such a weak question 40%
only 40% of college freshmen strongly
agreed with the statement and it goes
down every year after that only 30% of
college seniors strongly agree with the
statement that it's safe to merely hold
unpopular positions on campus and most
striking of all only sixteen point seven
percent of college professors strongly
agreed with the statement that it's safe
to hold unpopular positions on campus
now how much of this is due to the fact
that academia has become kind of has
become more concentrated especially
liberals uh I'm the tenure committee
hiring other liberals and things and
people tend to get extreme the more that
they talk to people like themselves
I definitely think groupthink is a big
contributor this problem you know if
you're only talking to people who agree
with you you end up in a situation where
people who don't agree with you or seem
to be basically heretics and therefore
they're there third they're fighting
truth they're try there fighting
Revelation and therefore they can be
shut down and I think that the it's one
of the things that I try to talk about
there's lots of legal fixes to this
problem that need to happen and
certainly the department education just
make things a billion times worse but
the cultural fix is that we somehow have
gotten out of the idea that intelligent
educated people it is a hallmark of
intelligent educated people that they
should seek out the intelligent person
with whom they disagree that has fallen
out of fashion on campus if that
actually were to go back into fashion if
that were to be considered what smart
people do that could make a lot of the
problems of fire see go away pretty
quickly and also for that matter make
our national discourse a lot less
tedious well how much of it is that let
me talk about the new Victorians people
said that the Academy is sort of going
back to its
founding roots when there were religious
schools that were intended to promote a
certain moral a religious point of view
and now that we've sort of circle back
with that we're social justice is the
new moral teaching that a college is
supposed to do and that that becomes the
prism you know the wish you you see
things and that and therefore you get
the same kind of Victorian rules for
what you can say and what you can't say
absolutely and that's been one of the
interesting things is how some of these
codes end up sounding even even though
they're nominally you know expressed
with an idea of being very progressive
and very forward-thinking that they end
up sounding like something out of
Anthony Comstock's mouth there we've
been doing speech code of the month at
fire since 2005 and we earned absolutely
no danger of running out of material but
Florida Gulf Coast University my mom's
British so I especially appreciate this
one there they had a blanket rule that
simply banned expressions deemed
inappropriate you know just something
look right out of Comstock at the same
time welcoat that's actually repeated
that was defeated at the University of
Connecticut but then revived verbatim at
Drexel University two fifteen years
later banned inconsiderate jokes and
wait for inappropriately directed
laughter so at the extremes they start
really sounding like Victorians and and
it really and it ends up they end up
coming to the same conclusions at the
extremes there's a case at University of
Denver that I'm gonna be talking about
where a professor was teaching a class
um that you know that es Russell this
could totally be a class talk but taught
by Thaddeus Russell
um the it's about taboos it's about
drugs and sex and masturbation and
taboos in in American history and that's
the content of the of the of the class
it's explained in the syllabus a student
was offended by the content of the
actual class not anything other than
that and that Professor remains a guilty
of harassment the University of Denver
and did the student take the class we
just saw the the course syllabus you
know I think it was I think it was
actually an anonymous report to I love
the story about Isaac rosenbloom at
Mississippi Heinz College in mrs.
and yeah this this contains strong
language I have I have a whole section
of the book that the subtitle of it is
swearing on campus and I have in
parentheses also known as don't read if
you can't abide cousin because it's
weird it's that I feel like people on
all over the spectrum there they can be
very good on freedom of speech but they
don't like the F word it's just strange
for me to run it as I live in Brooklyn I
take this for granted but this is a case
of a guy who was finishing up his degree
in order to become a paramedic he after
class he found out that he got a
particular grade he got that I forgot
what it was but he looked at it goes man
this is gonna [ __ ] up my GPA to another
student the professor starts shouting
I'm saying you can't talk like that in
my presence you're going to detention so
it's clearly a professor like this guy
is a is 29 years old detention yeah he
had his permanent record yeah he has two
children and he's studying to be a
paramedic and they found the student
guilty and it's amazing because we
actually have this whole is told
testimony on tape it's like this weird
surreal that was a teacher by the way
especially I forgot what her name was
tried not to focus too much on her
because if it just died there it
wouldn't have been as big of a deal
right but they had a hearing and this
the student is is you know he's quoting
papers she's quoting Supreme Court
opinions he's coming off as very
intelligent and nonetheless in this
hearing they find him guilty of flagrant
disrespect he um he's gonna lose his
Pell grant and there's and they're
basically trying to make the argument
that a paramedic you know but going on
the real world you can't be expected to
swear it's like dude if I'm having a
heart attack and a paramedic shows up
and like looks at me and goes oh fudge
like I'm gonna I'm gonna be a little
weirded out by that
why is it I mean how did it come to be
progressive to have you know sex codes
and and and this you know that it's a
strange thing
how I'm how we got there you know I
can't exactly say how but it definitely
is sort of the more thing out of hostile
environment law combined with groupthink
combined with the fact I mean honestly I
think it's the fact I went to Stanford
for Law School
and that was one of the more sort of it
was a culture that didn't quite
understand that how much it was
reflecting a very upper-class way of
looking at the world but they thought of
this is progressive so everybody should
think this way um so I think there's a
lot of groupthink I think there's a lot
of wealth and I think there's a lot of
this weird kind of weird sort of like
what I refer to a selectively
uptightness
that the people are able to turn on and
turn off that people have just gone much
to schooled in the ability of like I
like that joke I like that joke I'm
offended and I'm gonna make a big deal
out of it partially because I might not
like you or what you're saying so when
our site has the majority here so we can
make the rules yeah exactly
so we've learned to selectively turn off
relativism and up tightness in the book
you talk about how the calls for this
kind of restriction on campus are being
mirrored off campus we're seeing the
same kind of trend toward that yeah that
concerns me is that you know I'll give
an example when I did an NPR show when
the when the book came out and there was
a student who was on my panel who was
supposed to be very Pro free speech and
she was really good on this stuff until
she was asked about policies at her own
college and she said oh yeah they're
very good I mean we do have a free
speech zone and you do have to wait ten
days in advance that you have to apply
ten days in advance to in order to use
it but they enforce it fairly so what
I'm afraid of is that we have a whole
generation that is so unthinkingly
deferential to Authority or at least
used to being told where they can sit
where they can speak what they can say
and when they can say it that it that it
poses a threat to the First Amendment
because the First Amendment can be
strong but if nobody knows it exists it
doesn't really matter all that much
anymore so you see the speech creeping
out late I talk in the book about how I
broke
right with often post and I wrote an
article about this um Harvard Law
Journal article that came to the defense
of speech codes of campus speech codes
with one it didn't cite any of the
opinions in which they've been defeated
and they've been defeated over and over
again over over the course of the years
but also with no sense that oh wait a
second I'm demanding that universities
have the power to censor me it struck me
that some of the stuff about obscenity
like where's Limbaugh calling senator
lugar a slot that it suddenly that word
became as if no one had heard that word
ever used in public about a woman and
and and and you saw these conniptions
that when Bill Maher was talking about
he'd used worst language about Sarah
Palin but that was all right it was
different from this and so we're seeing
I mean how much of it is just people
faintly feigned outrage basically
absolutely that's that's one of its
funny it's one of my favorite sections
of my book just way to put it but I
talked about the problem with feigned
outrage because first it was a sandra
fluke thing and then people were turning
on bill Mart about what he said about
Sarah Palin but they it reached its
stupid crescendo when Robert DeNiro at a
democratic fundraiser with regards to
Callista Gingrich makes this joke are we
really ready for a white first lady it's
cute it's a titter joke like it's not
like a joke that really should have been
anybody but Newt Gingrich goes on saying
I'm demanding an apology for that joke
and Bill Maher wrote a piece that in the
New York Times that we thought was great
that was we should have a no offense day
no famed outrage day that we need to we
need to stop pretending we're so we
can't bear the words that people use
against us because it's just BS and it's
just tactical and I totally agreed with
it but I emphasize in the book but you
gotta understand this stuff has been
weaponized and perfected on campus for
decades and if you really want to stop
this sort of weird dance where people
say I'm offended and therefore you
should shut up now we have to start
calling it out on college campuses I've
got one more question and then we'll
open it up what our alumni do
and what kennel I'm gonna do about
campus I mean do people I mean I I've
seen this at the school I went to Yale
has gotten a lot of attention from fire
it's been ranked and and Harvard has
there been any consequence from do these
schools pay a penalty for suppressing
free speech and and and for taking away
students rights to a fair trial the
thing is you know um alumni are much
more powerful than they know that when
when we have a case in which we know
that alumni are actually writing
universities saying this is outrageous
or I'm not giving to you anymore it can
take a handful of alumni to to get a
university to go oh never mind never
mind because these aren't they're not
necessarily brave people but the so we
really want to get more more help from
alumni but I think there's a fatalism
about how much they can actually help
that is completely unwarranted they want
to get their own grandkids in is that
the I think that probably doesn't help
any okay
I do have any questions from the
audience here
hi you I know that in your book you you
tell another kind of story about was it
a southern universe some university that
was suppressing or Christian groups
opportunity to show Mel Gibson's movie
at the same time that another group was
doing you know [ __ ] a [ __ ] Jesus
sculpture or some sort yeah that group
speak the kind of people that you know
maybe wouldn't come to meetings like
this are being oppressed as well by
speech let me ask you a second question
as well just why do you think things
were better in 1970 or circa in 1965 why
didn't things deteriorate so that's the
other broad question so that's my two
questions okay well the first one is a
case that people you know and I try to
repeat this case aloud it's a place
called Indian River College in Florida
it has 112 thousand students it's not
even a small college but they told a
Christian group there that it could not
show Mel Gibson's Passion of the Christ
which people may not know this but it
remains the at least at the time was the
highest the box office rated non-english
language film of all time it's it's an
Aramaic for people I don't know and they
were told that they couldn't show it
because it was offensive and
controversial and that it was rated R
meanwhile they were hosting a skit that
included on campus that included
something called [ __ ] for Jesus that
was about masturbating to the crucifix
and we were very clear about this that's
protected and so is watching The Passion
of the Christ it's absolutely outrageous
that you would have you know allow one
and ban the other but the double
standards these systems cannot exist
without double standards because when
you look at the plain language of these
speech codes everyone's guilty of
violating them but they're only able to
exist with an implicit speech with Apple
is a double standard so the double
standards are always striking with
regards to the the second question why
did it get so much worse you know fire
doesn't pretend that there was ever some
perfect golden age for free speech on
college campuses my dad came here in the
1950s he thought that universities
University Wisconsin was much more
uptight than schools he went to in
German
he but there was a free speech movement
and it did actually change things and I
joke sometimes that there was a perfect
week in 1977 when the old censorship had
ended and the new one had begun yet
when when everybody when everything was
fine Virginia posture oh by the way who
used to be the editor of reason said
yeah you're totally right I went to
school I went to Princeton in the late
70s it actually was pretty much perfect
in that respect but yeah it does seem to
be cyclical though and the the instant
that the instinct to censor is something
that I think is just fundamentally human
that's one of the reasons why the First
Amendment is so brilliant it says you're
gonna be biased you're gonna figure out
an argument for shutting people down who
have opinions you dislike so let's do
this let's have this brilliant idea
let's take that entirely off the table I
just wanted to dispute something you
said I don't think I don't think Newt
Gingrich was the nadir of stupidity
after the Senator flu thing look thing I
think that came when not Gloria Allred
are the famous feminist lawyer from
Southern California wrote to the
District Attorney of Palm Beach County
Florida asking him to investigate rush
limbaugh on charges of criminal libel
under a statute dating from the 1880s
that makes it a crime obviously this
hasn't been enforced in a long time it
makes it a crime to question for to
accuse a woman falsely of a wad of
chastity which by the way since fluke
was saying she needed free birth control
and she's not married I think Limbaugh
is presumptively innocent of that
whatever you think of what he said but I
think that was the dumbest start the
dumbest Norman I will be in the next
book totally just stealing the mic sorry
about that
just to follow up what Jean asked has
had the same kind of thought yeah the
free speech movement in the early
sixties that was the beginning of the
new left as it used to be called or the
old new left okay so maybe 1977 Virginia
passed rels undergraduate career was the
it was the highlight but was there a
large cultural thing that happened is
there an event that you can point to in
the earlier mid
because by the time I was a freshman in
86 this was what was happening that that
the new regime was happening was
starting to begin
was there any precipitating events it's
really impossible to know but definitely
what Harvey silverglade and Alan Korres
the two founders of fire attributed to
in their book the shadow university was
a overwhelmingly positive thing by the
early 1980s but he actually by the late
seventies you had an unprecedented
number of minorities and openly gay
people and women going going to colleges
but and there was friction there were
people actually god forbid getting in
arguments with each other and not like
each other being nasty to each other
here and there but the idea was you know
as a lot of people said just throw up
the white flag essentially to redefine
this all as harassment and just ban
people from interacting with each other
so the overall theory is that is that
from an overwhelmingly positive
development came this really sort of
restrictive idea but the problem is it
fed into this idea that administrators
and and and are the heroes that there
are the protectors of everybody else's
right and the problem with that is it
ends up developing kind of like that's
why I think it's so comparable to
Victorianism because there's a sense of
sort of like I am the one true defender
of goodness and right and that means you
should shut up and that that takes on a
that takes on a life of its own theme of
stridency that you're hitting on is it
necessarily the far left or necessarily
the far right is how does that work in
terms of the polarity of the political
spectrum but that's a great question it
is a mess when it comes down to it who's
gonna censor who and for what reason
sometimes and I'm very clear about this
in the book it's not all political
correctness a lot of it is you criticize
the university and I'm going to punish
you as I always refer to this it's old
Dean wormer stuff it's not any any real
you know surprise in that sense so
sometimes you'll have someone who
considers himself very far left who's
awesome on freedom of speech and
sometimes you have just a careerist
administrator who just wants to punish
somebody for it for hurting the branding
of the university but in other cases you
have people who are true believers they
think that speech should be stopped it'd
be if it's offensive to anyone
particularly me
and that uh and and those and some cases
can be the most intractable people to
fight I wanted to ask about high schools
in 1968 in high school I wrote a an
essay for my high school paper that got
parents so upset that they they started
boycotts in the school administration
the school board with withheld funding
saying we said it cried freedom of
speech and they said you can say
anything you want we just don't have to
pay for it so they told us to raise our
own funds so we wrote a play to raise
money to be performed entirely in the
nude and we got all our money back so
whereas today I feel like if I had done
that I would be under you know
psychological scrutiny and lockdown or
and all I had done was suggest that
because hunters would transpose on our
land and shoot up our pet rabbits I just
suggested that hunters should shoot
their own pets not ours
that's all it's suggested so and that's
what got everybody upset so what happens
now what happens in high school and art
have you been involved in those cases
and is are the laws any different like
you know it's a minor it's a great
question and again we got it a lot you
know I've said this almost since I've
been with fire and I've been with fire
now for nearly twelve years is we get a
lot of ridiculous cases submitted to us
by high school students but you know my
belief is that in order to be an
effective organization it's a good idea
for a non-profit to stay narrow and
until you've actually solved the problem
you were founded to solve then you
should not be looking for mission creep
but the problem in K through 12 is
ridiculous
Lenora can it's gonna can attest to this
there needs to be a group like fire for
high schools and if someone wants to
found that and run it I will get behind
them and push I've I've been saying that
for years and I want there to be an
order but but one of the reasons another
reason why we don't get involved in high
school cases is the law is very
different they are minors and there's a
there's a series of bad Supreme Court
cases starting in the 80s
but most recently finishing in a case
called Frederick that severely limit the
free speech rights of high school
students the high-water mark being the
tinkerer a black armband case from the
late 1960s and since then it's just been
downhill I mean the Frederick case which
is the famous bong hits for Jesus case
was one of the strangest opinions I have
ever read in Supreme Court history that
you have a Chief Justice Roberts trying
to trying to puzzle over what bong hit
what do bunk is for Jesus meant and so
he keeps on putting brackets into it
it's like perhaps it meant brackets do
long it's for Jesus or bonk it's for
Jesus brackets are good and I'm like no
you can't censor something because of
the bracketed meaning it's a freaking
joke but the situation for K through 12
when it comes to free speech has gotten
really bad they're trying to give Jesus
bunk it wasn't possibly so yes there
needs to be a fire for K through 12
okay thanks I just have a quick question
because you're talking about a closed
environment which is school further
education and so forth but you sort of
tantalized us by saying that this is
going outside of that closed environment
and you know as somebody who's a little
bit active on Twitter I have noticed
something like this happening on Twitter
a balkanization where people just talk
to each other I wonder if you could
explain to us how this has translated
from the campus environment to for
example Twitter or Facebook or any of
the other sort of chatty media where we
are yeah actually this is something that
I'd like to write another book on I got
it I talked about it briefly or actually
I said come it's a theme I come back to
a lot about sort of a hyperpolarization
in the country but what I find what
you're talking about is what you know
negroponte you called the daily me that
essentially in in cyber environments you
can you you can find like-minded people
and you can only talk to them and only
get your information from them which
leads to polarization and that's
something that I you know as someone who
is very interested in cyber law I I
would I was always very fascinated by
but what I actually find even more
interesting is the is the premise by
Bill Bishop in a book called the big
sort which came out in 2008 which is it
not just that we're living in cyber
environments of the of the like-minded
that we're living increasingly in
counties and communities of increasing
increasing ideological similarity and
when you have the situation you end up
really really accelerating the process
of group polarization and viewing
outsiders as heretics and insiders is
good or at least you know bound by our
community rules and my point is I don't
believe that it's higher education
that's caused this problem but it's our
best hope for fixing it that we that we
could actually be educated people would
say you know what am I am i stereotyping
what people in Kansas think am i
stereotyping what what a a theist think
if you're Christian or what Christians
think if you're atheist that's that's a
good critical thinking mindset to have
but really what we're doing more of
particularly and we're not even at the
point where we're not encouraging people
to to
to each other we're actually actively
discouraging them to say anything that
could hurt anyone's feelings which makes
this idea of actually becoming more open
and actually trying to get make people
suspicious of their own confirmation
bias is impossible if you can't if you
can get in trouble for just for speaking
your mind am I am I free to ask a
politically incorrect question you bet
it seems like we're shifting to a state
of affairs where feelings are taking the
place of actions and I guess my question
is to what extent do you think that the
increasing numbers I think there's a
fair case to be made that women pay more
attention to feelings than men do and to
what extent do you think that increasing
numbers of women on campus or in
elementary schools or high schools is
giving greater preference to feelings
and being offended than the abstract
principle of free speech I certainly
have heard that that argument made
before both by people who are being
critical of it and by people who are
actually saying and this is a good thing
this is part of the sort of the
feminization process of campuses I'm
pretty agnostic to the overall theory
partially because I actually see a lot
of what I do and I'm very aware of this
is that a lot of the problems that you
see today are problems of comfort there
are problems of comfort and wealth and
and and then essentially it just makes
sense that in the late 19th century as
Britain was getting much much richer
they start becoming really obsessed with
how how much they can show off their
status through showing off excessive
displays of morality and excessive
displays of self-righteousness
so even without an increased influence
of women I think you would still have
this when you reach a certain level of
comfort people start engaging in these
kind of competitive displays of morality
so I think that this would be a problem
under any circumstances just from a more
affluent more stratified more isolated
society like you currently see in higher
education Greg could you talk a little
bit about how the protections of the
First Amendment differ between high
schools public
Versa t's private universities and
general life absolutely so K through 12
particular K through 8 yet you have the
lowest first amendment protections at O
so the first distinction is private
colleges are bound by the First
Amendment public colleges are not I will
get back to that sorry private colleges
are not bound by the First Amendment
public colleges aren't you thinks well
but it's indirect though that that's
that's the Leonard law the Leonard law
implies First Amendment standards to
non-sectarian colleges in the state of
California so so public colleges are
bound by the First Amendment it just
doesn't mean very much in K through
eight it doesn't mean it means more but
not much more in high school and it
means a lot in higher education there's
very strong case law about the free
speech rights of faculty and students in
higher education going back to 1950s a
case called Sweezy
where they actually end the quote about
academic freedom with and if we can put
any straitjacket on our nation's
students are cut our nation will
stagnate and die it's really strong
language coming on the Supreme Court and
and it's been consistently consistently
quite good on the Supreme Court level
private colleges are not bound by the
First Amendment but our overall stances
is that they meet they are bound by
their promises so Yale and Harvard
promised freedom of speech to high
heaven they have glowing glowing
promises and it makes sense to hold them
to these promises I'm not just out of
fairness but they get some of the best
students in the country they get some of
the best faculty in the country and they
get literally billions of dollars in
donations over the years partially by
portraying themselves as a citadel of
freedom of speech they better deliver on
that I'm normally not a vindictive
person that's it that's a great opening
possibly possibly my ex-wife might have
a slightly different opinion but
generally the biggest problem that we
see and in my mind one of the reasons
this continually gets worse and and Alan
Coors and Harvey silver grades original
book the shadow University was to which
yours is really an incredible sequel but
it really has been around for a long
time with all the good that's being done
I can't remember
anybody who's gotten in trouble no
matter how ridiculous the position the
most ridiculous points that were made
going back to Alan and Harvey and in
your book it seems that virtually nobody
has had to pay a price for it and until
somebody does I can't see that it's
gonna change
prior to this letter coming out on
Thursday we were making great progress
on this and and the the big villain of
the beginning of this book the the the
the president who punished the student
for the collage protesting the parking
garage after years of litigation was
held personally liable for this and that
was a that was a part of the fired
strand legal strategy is to pierce
something that's kind of a boring term
but to pierce qualified immunity and
actually start getting some of these
that bad if bad actors found personally
liable any and so was fifty thousand
dollars it's supposed to come at his own
pocket but they're also asking for two
million dollars in attorneys fees that
will get administrators attention that
will get campuses attention and there's
been a couple of piercing of qualified
immunity the problem is we've made such
progress on this but now that the the
but the standard is that you knew or
should have known or had actual notice
that you're violating the Constitution
and then you can be held personally
liable and this has been fires grand
plan for a very long time but the
Department of Education an apartment of
justice letter really throws some
ambiguity into that because now
university is even if they're knowingly
violating the Constitution to have no
regard for whatsoever can now say the
federal government made me do it so we
got to work cut out for us
so one of the things that I'd noticed
from this was this kind of idea of the
people who are making the accusations
claiming that they're the ones that are
having free speech to make the
accusation do you know I mean like
that's why it's so frustrating
because as somebody that's saying
something you're saying I'm saying this
but the people of Center I'm offended by
this which is why I get to say I'm
offended by it
well the thing is it kind of like you
know counter speech is the solution
ultimately and if you just say I'm
offended and you're a jerk for saying
that then great we're on we're on both
of your sides that's the way you're
supposed to resolve this stuff but when
you say I'm offended and therefore
someone has to be punished for it then
then you're then you lose us then we're
like no no no that's not the way it's
supposed to work but a really striking
case of how muddled this stuff gets was
a case that I talked about about Sally
Jacobson in at Northern Kentucky
University I talked about in the book
and there was a pro-life display on
campus it was a bunch of little white
crosses it was approved by the by the
student government not by the
administration it was you know a loud
protest and Sally Jacobson who's a
professor there it goes in front of her
class and says I want my sink we should
exercise our First Amendment rights to
destroy this display and they go out and
they destroy it and even afterwards when
they're asking her about it she really
seemed to believe that she had a First
Amendment right to destroy someone
else's speech and you see that you see
this idea repeated over and over again
and how often we have to say no there's
been a bunch of cases where students
have shut down speeches by like visiting
dignitaries by buy speakers and then
sometimes we'll come to fire for help
and we're like you're on the wrong side
of free speech we're not gonna help you
uh as someone who very recently left a
college campus one of the things I've
noticed is that while formal actions
taken to restrict free speech certainly
are not as rare as they should be are
relatively infrequent compared to
informal ways of stifling free speech
and part of that I think is because as
you said there's this tolerance of it
from people who are you know if a
professor says that's offensive you
shouldn't say that most kids will say
okay I won't do that
so I'm wondering obviously that's
something that's much more difficult to
litigate and I'm not sure if it even
should be litigated and and so my
question is what are your insights on
how best to fight that informal speech
code that's an absolutely terrific
question um the you know I think a lot
about this about trying to call out some
of these weird behaviors that we've
gotten so used to engaging in to sort of
a trump card against people who say
things that we dislike and and I think
everybody at this point engages these to
some degree where you say I'm offended
or I don't want to talk about it or how
dare you we're just too quick to do that
kind of stuff so calling that stuff out
I've even tried this out and some
friends you know when someone
immediately starts grandstanding I'm
kind of like you know tone it down let's
actually talk about if the fact you're
offended is an emotional state let's
talk about what actually is happening
here and it's actually worked a couple
different cases where we proceeded then
to actually have a real serious
conversation about it but I think you
have to get people one you have to
pierce the bubble you have to actually
be able to say you know that these are
our values that it's actually to some
degree we've watched First Amendment
organizations of other First Amendment
organizations across the country in
different cases fall trip over
themselves saying well this speech is
offensive I defend it nonetheless we try
to avoid doing that because that muddies
the water we're saying kind of like no
this is a principle it would be
ridiculous to say that we're apologizing
for the speech in the first place the
principle is what we're talking about
here this is a system that we believe
that we believe in but I do think that
one of the things that could really help
ever been to the IQ squared
debates the terrific series and it
points out this you know almost
forgotten idea that debates on meaty
topics on college campuses can actually
be fun that they can be joyous that you
can actually have some fun you could
have Pete you can even have smart people
who disagree I spoke at Yale um a couple
of weeks ago and I had um no no sorry oh
my god I got confused I spoke at Harvard
gags and
yikes and um and there was someone there
it was a conservative student explaining
kind of like yeah I try to actually have
have them you know debates on meaty
topics but they'll protest if I have
someone on the other side of some of
this stuff and so that's teaching people
that debate and and and and discussion
can be fun is something that you know
they have orientation programs at
universities where I think they really
emphasize sort of like you're right you
know to use a sort of somewhat hackneyed
term you're right not to be offended
what they really should be doing is
preparing people that it's for the idea
that debate and discussion is awesome
and can actually be really delightful I
think if you change expectations that
that's the way you start addressing it
speak to whether and where you've
actually seen unlikely allies on
campuses fire it's all about unlikely
allies I I'm extraordinarily proud of
when we do amicus briefs you know having
you know we'll have the camp Christian
Legal Society the ACLU David Horowitz
you know you know like all on the same
amicus brief you know we've got atheists
and conservatives and liberals oh and
there was one one where we had all that
entire group and the the Center for
sexual expression all on the same one so
we're always making unlikely allies and
I think that you know in some cases when
we were fighting free speech zones at
first at West Virginia University we
were working with a group called
students for economic justice and they
were awesome on this stuff they were
having and definitely there other groups
with similar names who have been
terrible on free speech issues but these
students were having protests of the
free speech zone and when students would
come up and like when and yell at them
they like oh you know take a bath hippie
they cheer the people yelling at them
for expressing expressing their freedom
of speech so we work yeah exactly so the
students get this better than the
administrators do and what when I when I
do shows about this when I do the
Huffington Post live about this I have I
felt like I walked into sort of a setup
where he had you had a muslim-american
student he had a conservative student he
had a very left-wing professor and a
professor we defended in one case and
the show ended up being almost slightly
boring because everybody's like yes
because they're ridiculous and speech
tones are ridiculous it's like okay well
we all agree then why does this stuff
keep happening and it's partially it you
know it's partially momentum it's
partially that the number of bureaucrats
on college campus has exceeded the
number of people involved in in
instruction as of 2005 it's just been
getting yeah it's just been getting and
that's on average it's just been getting
bigger and bigger and when you have so
many people whose job is to police the
daily lives of students shock upon shock
they start overdoing it
so the ninth the one good piece of news
at that is that the reason why college
has gotten so expensive and the reason
why free speech and due process are in
such trouble on college campuses is one
of the same and having some good
competing models of universities that
are leaner and meaner could really make
a big difference thank you very much
everyone for participating thank you
Greg Luke and I for for some great
thoughts tonight for a great book on
learning liberty and thank you a Museum
of sex and and Julian and Kendra and
reason thank you Gary
enjoy our school